simple pas des voyous tout ça vient dans
l'histoire que parce qu'on roule sur des
gros timo gans un tout de suite derrière
deux endroits où les jours dans les
journaux bien marquer les blousons noirs
ont fait si on fait ça et bien c'est
quoi rêver notamment nouveau après on
fait du bruit ça y est tout de suite on
a des blousons noirs ça coûte bien
gilbert ya une chose qui s'impose à toi
qu'est-ce que tu en auras foot
absolument rien du tout tiens métier -
c'est bon ben moi je suis mécanicien
jamais tu y es gilbert c'est oui che
c'est d'accord on est bien alors alors
on comptait treize mille jeunes
délinquants 54 on en a dénombré plus de
19000 l'an passé et ça continue
n'hésitons pas à employer les grands
mots la marée montante de la délinquance
juvénile ça n'est pas seulement du
cinéma ou la littérature
c'est un fake enregistre des froides
statistiques officielles de l'éducation
surveillée
quelles en sont les causes que fait-on
contre elle que faudrait-il faire c'est
ce que l'on va tenter de déterminer en
fait enquête au long de laquelle m
hélène falconetti avocats la cour
spécialistes de ces problèmes va nous
conduire le problème de l'enfance
délinquante apparu longtemps sera menée
à la lutte contre l'alcoolisme la misère
le taudis
mais aujourd'hui on se rend compte qu'il
s'agit d'un problème plus complexe car
la dissociation familial qui est la
cause essentielle de la délinquance
juvénile elle existe aussi où l'on
trouve le luxe la facilité la faiblesse
des parents d'ailleurs l'été des boys en
angleterre les chemise fleurie à
singapour est ce que chez nous nous
appelons les blousons noirs
ils se recrutent un peu dans toutes les
classes de la société et ils s'indignent
parfois avec raison d'être
automatiquement identifié les
délinquants dieu merci les bandes
d'enfants comme est souvent plus de
chahut que de crimes véritable plus de
chahut que le délit mais cette
constatation
elle ne résout pas le problème elle ne
fait qu'approfondir la question cette
question
la vraie question ce n'est pas à la
délinquance
ces vignes adaptation or ce phénomène
inquiète l'opinion publique parce que
l'idh adaptation semble se généraliser
la cinéma le cinéma
la presse nous montre nous dépeignent
des moeurs une certaine jeunesse qui
n'est pas sans inquiéter toutes les
familles personne ne peut se croire à
l'abri et chacun d'entre nous
s'interroge pourquoi pas demain mon
enfant remarquez qu'avec l'évolution
sociale la famille très vite partage son
rôle traditionnel d'éducatrice avec
toutes sortes d'autres milieux l'école
l'apprentissage des mouvements de
jeunesse et surtout la rue la rue
provocatrice avec ses starlettes ses
footings et c'est aussi aujourd'hui sa
tâche ton à utiliser tout le temps passé
dans la rue dans un but de prévention
dans le but que poursuit le club des
jeunes montent
fo
je
ce club de jeunes il y en a quatre ou
cinq en france nous sommes allez le
découvrir à rouen dans un de ces
quartiers où l'on osait à peine il y a
quelques années s'aventurer la nuit
tombée les jeunes du club vous les
entendez déjà ils ont désormais leur
maison où l'on joue longchamp toulon
chahutent elle remplace la revel où le
biscuit c'est la baraque ou si l'on
préfère le club des pigeons c'est eux
qui ont choisi le nom
le terrain était municipal les planches
et le ciment les tuiles ont été
subventionnés tout le reste c'est leur
oeuvre celles aussi et surtout de
bernard et mots leurs éducateurs là
l'idée m'est venue que moi même j'étais
gosse dans le quartier je suis né dans
ce quartier et que je n'ai jamais eu
locales on aurait une ire ni deux ni de
bâtiments pour me distraire vers les
loisirs
j'ai pensé que les garçons de 17 ans
maintenant avait le même problème tu
parles moi j'en avais 17 et qu'il
fallait peut-être pensé avoir un local
où ils pourraient plus ils pourraient
passer leurs loisirs après le travail ou
le samedi après midi ou le dimanche est
aussi avoir un local pour pouvoir penser
à organiser des loisirs prise éducatif
et peut-être des campings et des
organisations de football ou autre et
les garçons sont ici chez eux
il ya toujours des initiés ce qu'il
décide exactement ce qu'ils veulent eux
mêmes ils ont décidé il ya cinq ans une
équipe de football
on a pu trouver des dirigeants dans le
quartier pour nous aider avant
d'expliquer de football où ils ont une
vision voulait après une équipe de boxe
bien c'est le carrossier quoi fort
plombent dire les quartiers compris des
places 2
payet en représailles et secrétaire et
et qui dirigent des clubs les clubs de
boxe et football c'est aussi les garçons
eux mêmes alors là qui décide d'un
camping où ils veulent aller comme il va
y aller
le temps qui va y aller le prix qu'on
mettra selon s'ils sont riches ou
barichello ces moments là et on peut
faire des activités qui décident eux
mêmes elle qui dirige et oman
je suis juste là pour toi tu vois pour
inciter quelquefois pour conseiller mais
jamais pour décider tout seul et je
pense que s'il y avait plus de barrages
comme ça dans différentes villes de
france et dans différents secteurs
on pourra plus parler de but
qualificatif ridicule comme nous au noir
ou teddy boy mais on aura une bande de
jeunes organisés et on éviterait
beaucoup de débit ou d'inadaptation que
l'on trouve parce qu' au manque de
locaux et de moyens sept cas l'espoir
sont informés je pense que c'est d'abord
une formation d'éducateur un peu spécial
qui seront se faire à se faire accepter
par les garçons et pour les filles
plus qu'une forme multi faut trouver
c'est un genre d'éducateurs qui vaudra
créé pour les difficultés actuelles
qu'on trouve l'algérie française et
d'organiser et e
qu'en pense-t-il je pense que vers la
raison que les jeunes ont besoin de
s'amuser n'a besoin de se distraire de
sur le soir contre 1 vient de travailler
quand on revient chez soi évidemment
dans le quartier c'est un peu
mal famés quoi c'est pas les quartiers
chics de rang alors évidemment les
jeunes on s'amuse dans notre milieu de
medio variés évidemment il ya la mj la
maison des jeunes j'ai pas du tout le
même milieu de nous c'est les étudiants
alors on a une baraka rue de robecq ici
alors les jeunes on se retrouve les
copains les copines on s'amuse jusqu'à
des 8 9 heures le soir avant de se
coucher le soir que dans la cale boulot
bien évidemment il faudrait qu'il y ait
plus géant maison comme bernard le
disait comme ça dans plusieurs quartiers
parce que les jeunes évidemment on
arrive à on est trop on arrive en étau
on arrive à faire des bêtises
précision c'est volontairement que nous
avons laissé dans l'ombre les visages
pour l'heure conserver un prudent
anonymat
mais en quittant la baraque une question
se pose encore
est ce que ce système là permet vraiment
de supprimer les délits voulait dire
l'inadaptation car c'est contre eux
d'inadaptation que lui de ces clubs de
prévention
et bien pas toujours mais le mérite
précisément du nouveau droit spécial
pour mineurs c'est de lutter contre
l'inadaptation sous toutes ses formes la
fameuse ordonnance de 1945 lutte contre
les manifestations extérieures de
l'inadaptation mais en 1958
on va beaucoup plus loin encore
puisqu'on s'attaque aux causes même de
l'inadaptation hier on punissait
aujourd'hui on adha
[Musique]